BEEP
Should I start like, oh hi, didn't see you there
I just did the clapper even though I'm not recording yet so I'll just
I'll just
...requests but it's either being completely ignored by the backend or it's just triggering this
Wait for that
Roll it
A cookie name session as well as the containing requests
Burp Scanner comes prepackaged with a wide range of scan checks targeting common vulnerability classes like SQL injection or XSS
Er, issue that is present behind this
Erm, request
They're also reducing the fast audit speed
This optimisation can be turned off completely on an insertion point type basis
That's still crap, sorry
I balled it, sorry
Alright
I can like, feel it going
It wasn't a good task
So
Aaaaahhh, that was going so well
Erm, so in the gin and juice shop example, that's my workspace
For f*** sake
Erm
Oh f***
Ah f***
Where is it? It was supposed to be there
Let's write the B check
Come on Dave
Better than that
Don't say that
Stop
On the API
That isn't from natural
Why am I
The gratification sounds on
Don't make B check
That's nice
Ha ha ha
Throw it down the lens
Tell us about your ideal Tuesday
My ideal Tuesday is working at Port Swigga
It's because it's my favourite
Ha ha ha ha
I'd be at a complete loss if I had just open Tuesdays with nothing to do
No structure and no code
No code
Ha ha ha ha
Ha ha ha